constitutional scholar jonathan turley
quote depp walks away with a far greater
victory in the rejection of herds
allegations another loser in this case
is the aclu which helped write the def
uh defamatory column this will now
magnify criticism of the role of the
aclu here with more is law professor fox
news contributor jonathan turley i found
your comments about the aclu interesting
but also
there were two things that really struck
me number one it was her admission
that well i didn't punch you but i hit
you
the allegation of defecating in one's
bed
and then we had this this whole notion
that she was complaining on one of the
tapes that he would walk into another
room and then another room and then
another room
which indicated to me that he was trying
to de-escalate is that a fair
interpretation
well not only is it a fair
interpretation it does appear to be the
interpretation of the jury
you know these this is trial turned
almost exclusively on credibility and
the jury clearly did not find her very
credible in fact they found her culpable
judging from this ruling the key to
remember is that as a public figure and
both of them were public figures
there was a higher standard a higher
burden to prove
called actual malice this jury found
that not only was she saying something
that was false but she did it with
malice and he really
ran the table on these counts they found
that for every one of these allegations
and so they clearly did reject her
allegations many of us noted that she
did not come across very well on the
stand
what did you think why do you
think the other loser in the case is the
aaclu
and while the jury awarded five million
dollars in punitive damages it was
reduced by the judge to 350 000 because
the commonwealth of virginia their law
limits punitive damages what are your
thoughts on those two things
well first of all i've never been a fan
of these caps on punitive damages jurors
tend to
give punitive damages in a very small
number of cases less than one percent
but they are there to register a jury's
outrage to say this is far beyond the
pale this is not just defamation it's
worthy of something more and i think
that states like virginia really do a
disservice by having these lower caps
i've been critical of this these caps
for a long time
now in terms of the aclu many people
have been critical of the aclu for years
and how it's changed it used to be an
organization was focused on free speech
due process
and this mission of protecting
individual rights it's become more and
more political it's drifted and in this
case we found out that aclu staffers
helped write this defamatory
opinion piece and many of us are saying
what what were you even doing in this
realm why were you even involved and the
aclu selected her as their spokesperson
for abuse
and they just simply seem to accept her
allegations and reject the claims of
depth that he was not an abuser and of
course that was the response of
hollywood and the media we've seen it
before
now it's not clear that this is going to
be a redemptive moment for depp you know
once tagged in that way it's hard to be
untagged
but the aclu really does deserve
really a front row seat in terms of
blame you know they played a critical
role they dr helped draft a defamatory
statement they disregarded the
countervailing arguments of death or the
possibility he might be innocent and
they elevated this person as the
presumptive spokesperson for all abused
spouses
all right uh jonathan turley always
great to have you thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else